>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Joan Weeks: Well good
afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
On behalf of all my colleagues and
in particular, Dr. Mary-Jane Deeb,
chief of the African and
Middle East Division,
I'd like to extend a very
warm welcome to everyone.
I'm Joan Weeks, head of
the Near East Section,
and sponsor of today's program
on the Orthodox Church in Georgia
since Independence
by Dr. Paul Crego.
Before we start today's program
and introduce our speaker,
I'd like to give you a brief
overview of the division
and the resources in the
hopes that you'll come back
and use the collections and this
reading room for your research.
This is a custodial division which
is comprised of three sections
that build and serve the collections
to researchers from
around the world.
We cover 75 countries
and over 22 languages.
The African section includes all
the countries of sub-Sahara, Africa.
The Hebraic section covers
Judaica and Hebraic worldwide.
And the Near East section
covers all of the Arab counties
of North Africa, the Near East,
all of the sections of Turkey,
Turkey Central Asia,
Iran, Afghanistan,
the Muslims in Western
China, Russia, the Balkans
and the people of the Caucuses.
So you know, this is
quite an extensive region.
And we're particularly pleased
today to be covering Georgia
in the former Soviet Republic.
So before we get started,
there are just a couple
of things I want to tell you about.
We also do programs and more
extensive programs than even this.
On June 10th, we have a very
exciting program with panels planned
from 8:30 to 3:30 over in
LJ119 on the Assyrians,
and the ancient peoples all through
the Middle East going into Turkey,
all of the different regions the
Assyrians lived and it's going
to be a very exciting program.
And as a further incentive, it
includes breakfast and lunch, so.
So, please mark that
on your calendar,
if you can join us at
some point with that.
Also another little housekeeping
thing, we'd like to invite you
to fill in the questionnaires
that you see in your seats.
This helps us to plan for future
programs to improve and see what you
like and what worked well for you.
Then also, we invite you to ask
questions but if you do ask them,
since we're videotaping this, you're
giving consent to be taped just
by default, so just
please be aware of that.
So, without further ado, I'd like
to invite Dr. Levon Avdoyan on here
to introduce our speaker.
>> Levon Avdoyan: Thank you, Joan.
It's wonderful to see so many
people here for this special event
and it is also a double pleasure to
introduce today's speaker to you,
Dr. Paul Crego, who is the
Senior Cataloging Specialist
and Acquisitions Librarian in
the Israel and Judaica section
with the Library of Congresses,
Asian and then Middle East Division.
He has been my vital partner
in the acquisitions of Georgian
and Armenian materials for 17
years now and has brought all
of these formats of
these collections
under bibliographic
control for your use.
Paul started at the
Library of Congress in 1999
and he's responsible for
books in Georgian, Armenian
and the languages of Ethiopia.
He holds a BA in Soviet
and East European studies
from Syracuse University, an MA
from Harvard University Soviet
Union program, a Masters of Divinity
from the Harvard Divinity
School and a PhD
in Theology from Boston College.
His publications include an
article with Professor Stephen Rapp,
the Conversion of K'art'li:
The Shatberdi Variant
from the Kekalazi [phonetic]
Institute a in Tbilisi,
the Ordination of St. Nino,
the Georgian Orthodox Church
in Christianity and Politics in the
21st Century, Monks and Monasticism
in Georgia in the 19th and 20th
Centuries, and he co-edited
with Stephen Rapp the Georgia Volume
in the Ash Gate Series, Languages
and Cultures of Eastern
Christianity.
Now, Paul was a staff fellow on
the John W. Kluge Scholarly Center
in 2007 to 2008 and spent his
years studying the historical
and cultural context of the
Aposean [assumed spelling] Conflict.
During his fellowship year, he
delivered a number of lectures
on issues of language, policy,
ethnic identity and ethnic
and national identity
in religious context.
He delivered papers at the
Manuscript Center in Tbilisi,
Princeton University
and the University
of Michigan at Ann Harbor.
In 2015, Dr. Crego presented
papers on the LGBT community
in the Republic of Georgia
including religious issues
in connections with that community.
One at the Georgia and at
the Crosswords Conference
at Bailey University and the
other at the Annual Meeting
of the Association for
Slavic East European
and Eurasian Studies
in Philadelphia.
Now, as you can see, he is
uniquely qualified to speak to us
on the subject of the
Orthodox Church
in Georgia since Independence.
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. Paul Crego.
[ Applause ]
>> Paul Crego: Picture it,
Ikalto, a small village in Kakheti
that is the eastern part of the
Georgian Soviet Socialist Republic.
Saturday afternoon, July
7th, 1990, the church-- oops.
There we go.
The church of the transfiguration
[foreign language] also known
as [foreign language], that
is Divinity of Godliness,
among the surviving buildings of a
famous medieval theological school.
Some of the great philosophical
and literary figures had
studied here during the hay day
of Georgia's Bagratid Dynasty
and its United Kingdom.
Not the least of it-- not the
least of these was the poet,
Shota Rustavelli, author
of the epic poem,
Vepkhist'q'aosani The
Knight in the Panther Skin.
The inside of the church was in poor
repair, water stains were visible.
The frescoes had been whitewashed
likely during the imperial Russian
period when some Georgian
churches had their Georgian
identities erased.
Icons of various styles had been
placed in a makeshift iconostasis.
Boxes of sand in front of the
icons held thin beeswax candles,
guttering in the soft,
warm, humid breeze.
In response to a question asked
from among our group of students
in Georgia for the first summer
school in Kartvelian studies
at Tbilisi State University,
the intuitus [phonetic]
or foreign tourists
service guide said
that it was not a working church.
Shortly after this
response, however,
the church bells began to chime.
And efficient to some
priestly order,
who appeared as if he had
been waiting in the very wall
of the church for his cue, placed
his service books on a lectern
and began to chant what was likely
the vigil of the resurrection.
We wondered whether we had witnessed
the first service in the new life
of this church of the
transfiguration.
Certainly, it was among
the first and represented,
iconified if you will the
transfiguration already well
underway in the Georgian Orthodox
Church and in the Georgian nation.
We were witnessing the
beginning of a remarkable new era
after nearly seven decades of
Soviet rule and its companion policy
of official state-sponsored atheism.
Although the Soviet Union did
not officially cease to exist
until the end of 1991, there are
two dates before the official end
that are essential starting points
for the concept of this paper.
The first is December 25th, 1977.
The Orthodox Church in Georgia
uses what's called the Old Calendar
so this is not Christmas,
but about two weeks before.
This was the day when the
current Patriarch Catholicos
of the Georgian Church,
Ilia II was enthroned.
Although that sometime-- although
it was some difficult times early
in his reign, these Catholicos,
Ilia II emerged in the 1980s
as the leader who would begin
to revive the Orthodox Church
in Georgia, he saw into a
future that held much promise
for a renewed church
when independence would
come again to Georgia.
The second date is April 9th, 1989.
It was on an early Sunday morning
when Soviet troops attempting
to disperse a demonstration
that had been developing
for several weeks fired
upon the crowd.
Nineteen people were
killed, among them 17 women
and many more were injured.
April 9th, 1989 was the day that
Soviet power died in Georgia.
Huge funeral liturgies
soon became rallies
for the resurrection of the nation.
Yes, there were political
structures that lingered
and the Communist Party shambled on.
For the Georgian people however,
communist rule was
body-hawking corpse
that was left then
only further to decay.
Within a year, there
was a box in front
of the Supreme Soviet Building, now
Parliament, and near the memorial
for the victims of April 9th.
And on this box, there was
an invitation for people
to place their Communist cards
into the dustbin of history.
In my brief time today, I
want to touch on a number
of different topics, the growth
of the Orthodox Church in Georgia,
church-state relations, the
Orthodox Church in society
and some publications of the church.
Let me pause at this point to thank
the African and Middle East Division
for inviting me to speak today
particularly Dr. Mary-Jane Deeb,
Chief, Joan Weeks, head of the Near
East Section and Dr. Levon Avdoyan,
my reference colleague in
matters Armenian and Georgian.
And if anyone wants to know, I have
been studying the Georgian language
since 1977 and a great deal
of my research concerning
the Orthodox Church
in Georgia involves reading
Georgian language sources.
The enthronement of Ilia
II as Catholicos Patriarch
of the Orthodox Church
in Georgia marked a point
after which this autocephalous
church began
to experience a reversal
of its fortune.
Although still in the time
of Breshnev [assumed spelling]
conditions in Georgia,
were more favorable than in some of
the other parts of the Soviet Union.
They continued to improve during
the Gorbachev years of Glasnost.
And there's Pearl Lenin
with his head bashed
in near the Natakhtari beer and soda
bottling plant, north of Mtskheta.
And what was Lenin's Square
when I was still there
in 1990 is now Freedom
Square with a statue topped
by a golden St. George
slaying his dragon.
Sadly, I missed Lenin coming
down by only about a week.
There had been rumors all summer and
we even got on the bus to go to free
or well, Lenin Square at the time
to see it come down but we heard
that the Georgians
forgotten ropes and such
by which to haul it down, anyway.
One of the most important
early events for the future
of the church was the opening of the
Tbilisi Spiritual Academy in October
in 1988 across from the
Zioni-- or Zion Cathedral.
This spiritual academy was
a companion to the seminary
in Mtskheta that had sometimes
been open during the Soviet period.
Before his enthronement,
Ilia II had been rector
of the Mtskheta Theological Seminary
from 1963 to 1972 and in 18--
1989, the ancient autocephaly
or self-governing status
of the Orthodox Church in
Georgia was officially recognized
by the patriarch of Constantinople.
The pace of change picked up in the
1990s and into the 21st century.
At his enthronement in 1977, only
five eparchies existed in Georgia.
There are now 50 including
seven outside
of the Republic of
Georgia's territory.
The first years of the new
century saw a great deal
of new church construction
and renovation.
The numbers of working churches
has increased from probably no more
than a couple of dozen
to over 850 by 2007.
We'll come back to that one.
Political leaders got in on the
building, Eduard Shevardnadze
who became the head of state in
1992 and was later elected president
after the 1995 Constitution
and served until the Revolution
of the Roses in November of 2003,
sponsored the reconstruction
of the Saint Nicholas Church
in the Narikala Fortress
overlooking the old part of Tbilisi.
He was by the way baptized
Giorgi [assumed spelling]
by the patriarch himself.
From before 1990, the Orthodox
Church in Georgia had begun
to make plans for the
construction of a new cathedral.
It was to be called, "The
Cathedral of the Holy Trinity".
A competition among architects was
held in 1990 but with the economy
in ruins in the 1990s,
it became impossible
to raise funds for
the new cathedral.
Finally, in the opening
years of the 21st century,
earnest construction began
with a large contribution
from Bidzina Ivanishvili,
who had made his money
in Russia during the 1990s when
that country's economy was largely
unfettered by regulation.
This is the same Ivanishvili, who
became Prime Minister of Georgia
after the Parliamentary
Elections of 2012.
Churches were built in Tbilisi
and elsewhere, others repaired
and put back together literally
putting the stones back up in order
for the churches again to exist.
This included the church
of St. David the Builder
who had been the ruler
of Georgia in its--
in the Middle Ages when Georgia
was at its largest extent.
This church was built on the
grounds of Tbilisi State University.
Let's look a little at the Church
of the Holy Trinity as it was built.
This was in late May or early
July 2000-- early June 2004.
You can see some of
the ornamentation
that was waiting to go up.
Not all of the technology
was 21st century.
This is an inside view
looking at the altar
where the iconostasis
now is and up on the top
of the apps overlooking the
altar, there are now tracings
in which a new mosaic of
Christ, the Pantocrator
or the Almighty will be put.
Just a view to show you how much
this new church dominates the
landscape in Tbilisi.
Another new church,
they're not all big,
is the small church
honoring St. Habo of Tbilisi,
an the early medieval martyr who
had been a perfumer in Baghdad,
moved to Tbilisi, converted
to Christianity
and then was martyred
for this trouble.
Monastery of the Holy Cross,
a 6th century establishment.
It's actually a first
year to its 4th century.
What's left there now is
as old as the 6th century.
It's a common place for
wedding parties to come,
so that a couple can be blessed
by the priests who were there.
Now, some of the women wear very
high heels and there's a slab
of concrete just down the
stairs from the church
that overlooks the Aragvi
and Mt'k'vari River or Kura
if you need a better
vowel to [inaudible].
But it's steep and they don't
want people wearing stilettos
to go over the cliff.
Another of the churches is a small
basilica called the Antakya Church
which is also Mcxeta, part of the
complex of the women's monastery
at the Samtavro Church in Mcxeta.
I'm afraid sometimes I
intrude the pictures,
that's Professor's Stephen Rapp
with whom I've done some
writing and editing.
Inside the Antakya Church, some
new frescos, this is the scene
with St. Nino equal to the Apostles
and Enlightener of the Georgia's--
Enlightener of the Georgians when
she prays for the pagan idols
to be blown off the hill.
So a significant part of her story.
Saint John the Baptist Monastery is
out in the Eastern part of Georgia
where things get very
dry and actually,
that cliff on the side is
where the monastery is.
There's a church inside
there and a refractory.
And there are also monks' residence
that's cut into the cliff and yes,
it was that blue that day.
My memory is giving to the
monastery, it was the feast
of Saints Helena and
Constantine so at 10 o'clock,
there was a festive lunch
and the red liquid coming
out of the coke bottles was of
course some good Georgian wine.
And they were at the time building a
new retreat center for the faithful
who would come on pilgrimage.
There's Saint Nino's Spring in Bodbe
and there is a large
tank of water here.
If you want to be fully sanctified,
you dunk your whole body in it,
I just kind of washed my head
but others were more exuberant
in their piety than I was.
This is down the hill from
the main cathedral of Bodbe
which means it's a
long climb back up.
And the Ananuri Church which
is as Georgian churches go,
a fairly new one, only
about the 17th century
and this was along the Aragvi River,
North of Mcxeta by an hour or so.
I couldn't resist this
picture of the little fisherman
who had a very ambitious project.
If he had filled that fishnet,
I think he would have had
fish to equal his own weight.
Another of the churches that
has been rebuilt and this one
to some controversy, this-- the
ruins of this cathedral were
on the UNESCO list and
former President Mike--
Mikheil Saakashvili as one of
his projects and also a project
of the church was to have this
rebuilt and it has not been rebuilt
to the specifications of many people
and much controversy has ensued.
An excursion into the countryside
reveals dozens if not hundreds
of small basilica churches
that have been cobbled together
like that Antakya Church
in the past generation.
One of the measures on taken--
undertaken by the church in
recent years is the repatriation
of all church buildings in the
Georgian territory of Svaneti.
This relatively remote part
of the country that stretches
into the mountains and
all the way to the border
with the Russian Federation
is covered
with small basilica type churches.
Many of these churches often
in the possession of families
within the villages had become
sites of non-Christian rituals.
The past decade, the patriarchate
has successfully recovered most
of these for Christian worship.
One source has indicated to me that
this was met with little opposition
and that in fact, the residents
of Svaneti were grateful
for the reestablishment of normative
Christian ritual and belief.
This is one of those churches.
A lot of these are about
900 or 1,000 years old.
This is Nakipari which is on
the end of the Inguri River,
a church name for St. George.
Svaneti is the only place
where I've seen churches
in honor of the prophet Jonah.
You will remember the whiney prophet
in the Hebrew Scriptures who--
whose famous line was, "Well,
God, I knew you'd change your mind
and you'd be nice to these people".
So perhaps, that is part
of the reason that Job
or Jonah gets churches
named for him.
That's one of my favorite pictures.
This is the Lamaria Church in
Ushguli which is just about as far
as you can get on the Georgian side
of the border as you're heading
into the Caucasus Mountains.
There is a glacier around the
corner that feeds the Inguri River
that finally goes to the Black Sea.
If you haven't been to
Svaneti, I recommend it.
So, a little bit about
church-state relations.
As noted above, when the Republic
of Georgia emerged from the rubble
of the Soviet Union as a
free and sovereign nation,
the Orthodox Church found itself
in a new political context.
After nearly seven decades
of militant and often crass
and bullying, government-sponsored
official atheism,
the Orthodox Church in Georgia
began again to exert its role
as a foundational institution
in Georgian society.
This foundation was supported
by Georgia's first post-Soviet
president, Zviad Gamsakhurdia
who ironically was driven from
power nearly at the same time
that the Soviet Union
finally collapsed.
He promoted a close relationship
with the Orthodox Church in part
as a guarantor of the Georgian
nation and its freedom.
In the political speeches, he
reminded his listeners that Georgia
as the lot, the word in Georgian is
[foreign language] of the Theotokos.
This is a reference to the story
that the apostles including the
Virgin Mary had divided missionary
assignments up by casting
lots and Georgia fell to Mary.
After a communication from her son
however, she came to understand
that she would not be able
to fulfill this mission
and Saint Andrew the
First-called took her place.
This understanding of the
special protection of Georgia
by the Theotokos became an
important theme for the church
and its relationship to the nation.
For the Orthodox Church in Georgia,
this has met not only a belief
in her protection but
a severe responsibility
to maintain the nation as worthy of
that protection in extreme cases.
This is an issue for those who seek
to rid the nation of
its impure others.
Gamsakhurdia's support had
been a little more than ironic,
steep as he was in the belief system
of Rudolf Steiner's anthroposophy.
Articles in the Orthodox churches
press attacking Steinerism appeared
only years after Gamsakhurdia's
death.
But it was clear that they
were kicking his corpse.
At first, the Republic of Georgia
operated under the 1921 Constitution
of the Democratic Republic
of Georgia
that had codified a
separation of church and state,
already in existence from the
early days of that republic,
a separation that have
actually been more separate
than the church had desired.
Georgia adopted a new
constitution in 1995 several years
after Shevardnadze
had returned to power.
This constitution enshrined
the Orthodox Church
as the first among equals,
freedom of religion is guaranteed,
but the constitution also speaks
of the historical precedence
of orthodoxy in Georgia.
No other religion or Christian
denomination is mentioned
as having this sort of
historical relevance.
Article 9 of the Constitution
as amended reads,
"The state proclaims the full
freedom of belief and confession
at the same time, acknowledging the
special role Georgia's apostolic
autocephalous Orthodox Church
has played in Georgia's history
and its-- and also recognizes
its independence from the state.
The relationship of Georgia's state
and Georgia's apostolic
autocephalous Orthodox Church is
to be defined by a
constitutional concordat.
The constitutional concordant--
concordat is to be
consistent in general
with all internationally-recognized
principles and norms,
specifically in the sphere
of fundamental human rights.
This constitutionally-mandated
concordat between the government
and the church was eventually
signed on October 14th,
2002 by President Shevardnadze
and Patriarch Catholicos Ilia II
at the Church of the
Living pillar Svetitskhoveli
in the old capital city of Mtskheta.
This document provided details for
the relationship of church and state
in Georgia and ratified its primary
status above other religious groups,
specifically the special status of
the church, included tax exemptions,
clerical release from
military service
and a special legal
status for the patriarch.
A commentary on the concordat,
its title translated into English,
Commentaries on the Constitutional
Concordat between the Government
of Georgia and Georgia's Apostolic
Autocephalous Orthodox Church,
was written by Davit Cikvaize.
He promoted the idea that the
concordat have made the Orthodox
Church in Georgia the
official state church.
While, I do not believe
this is technically
so the Orthodox Church
is often operated
as though it had been made such.
This is especially noted in
its reported interference
in the property rights of other
churches and religious communities.
The ambiguity concerning the
status of other religions
and other Christian denominations
was somewhat nearly rated
with the religious law that
came into effect in July 2012.
The first two readings
of this legislation had
included only what was referred
to in some documents as the seven
historic religious communities,
orthodoxy, Catholicism, the
Lutherans, Baptists, Jews, Muslims
and the Armenian Apostolic Church.
Jews have been present in Georgia
and other South Caucasian
territories since early
after the Babylonian captivity.
Muslims, since the second generation
after Mohammed and Armenian
and Georgian Christians have lived
intermingled since the early days
of Christianity in
the South Caucasus.
Catholic missionaries were present
in Georgia in medieval times.
Baptists and Lutherans have been
present since the 19th century
and as a result of
religious movements coming
by way of the Russian empire.
In between the second and
third readings of the 2012 Law,
the Committee on European
Integration widely expanded the
number of religious
communities to conform
to those recognized by
the European Council.
The Orthodox Church had not
been consulted on this change
and reacted adversely to the
broad expansion of the new law.
After some reconsiderations
of its public stance,
the Senate of the Orthodox
Church in Georgia backed
down from its most severe
criticism of the new law.
At this point, the church
seemed to have realized
that its overreach was
leading to bad publicity,
not only in Georgia
but around the world.
At the same time, the
Senate insisted
that the parliament
should consult with it
when laws affecting religion
were under consideration.
There is generally an ongoing
in complex relationship
of the Orthodox Church in
Georgia with not only its place
in the nation, but also its
relationship with the government
that promotes a European or a
Western orientation complete
with the promotion of
civil and human rights.
The Orthodox Church in this time
of independence has been anxious
about the way in which they
understand how freedom can quickly
become a free for all sort
of attitude toward
ethical and moral norms.
There is no question that the
Orthodox Church is the most
respected institution
in Georgian society
and that Patriarch Catholicos Ilia
II is the most respected individual
in the Republic of Georgia.
This has been so for
most of the years
since Georgia regained
its independence.
It is as much so now as the campaign
for the October Parliamentary
Elections have revealed a widespread
disdain for many of the political
parties and coalitions currently
in the Georgian Parliament.
On the other hand, it has been
difficult for the Orthodox Church
as for churches of many sorts
in post-Soviet states to adjust
to the new social and political
realities of the late 20th
and early 21st centuries.
The effect of seven decades
of Soviet rule on Georgia,
in the Georgia on the
Orthodox Church
and other religious communities
cannot be overestimated.
Once of the historical developments
or better, non-developments
of the Orthodox churches in
Soviet time and space was
that it prevented these communities
from the sort of modern discussion
and debates that characterized
Christianity in other parts
of the world in that century.
In the few churches that
survived the Communist regime,
liturgy was preserved but talk of
modernizing liturgical language
or the education of
faithful or involvement
in social activities was forbidden.
After the fall of the Soviet Union,
the Orthodox Church in Georgia,
in response to the dire economic and
social needs of the Georgian people,
became involved again
in the social sphere.
Since 1994, the church's Lazarus
Foundation has been a mainstay
of large-scale relief
work in society.
One of the more difficult
adjustments
in this new time has
involved ecumenical relations.
For a time, the church in Georgia
played a role, if only a small one
in the global ecumenical movement.
Ilia II was for time a president
of the World Council of Churches.
While this title did not mean
that he was involved in the day
to day operations of the council,
the position was a recognition
of Ilia II's important
and the revival of post--
of the churches in
post-Soviet space.
In the 1990s, the Orthodox churches
in general and the Orthodox Church
in Georgia in particular,
began more closely
to assess their participation in
dialog with other Christian bodies.
Some of the non-canonical churches
calling themselves Orthodox had
proclaimed ecumenism a heresy and
this notion began to be expressed
in all parts of orthodoxy including
Georgia's two non-canonical Orthodox
churches that have
existed in Georgia.
One of them styled at first as the
true Orthodox Church of Georgia,
was under the authority of--
the Metropolitan of Boston.
Yes, Boston, Massachusetts,
at the Monastery
of the Holy Transfiguration
in Brooklyn, Massachusetts.
The other was led-- the other was
a small group led by the violent
and notorious Father
Basil Mkalavishvili
and under the authority of a
Schismatic Greek Church known
as the Synod of Resistance.
Some of the monks of the Orthodox
Church were also almost in schism
from the main church over
the issue of ecumenism.
Their influence was part of
the Georgian church's decision
to leave both the World Council
of Churches and the Conference
of European Churches in 1997.
Officially, the Georgian Synod
cited that, "World Council
of Churches leaderships continued
efforts to endow the organization
with unified ecclesiological
functions", and the WCC's alleged
"failure to take interests of the
Orthodox Church fully into account"
as reasons for their action.
Many of the anti-ecumenical
monks were disciplined
for their rebellion
despite the fact that some
of their agenda was enacted
and has remained the position
of the Orthodox Church
in Georgia ever since.
As an example of this in
the preliminary meetings
of the Orthodox churches
for the Holy and Great Synod
of the Orthodox Church
soon to take place on Crete
and in subsequent articles, Georgian
authors have been very critical
of any ongoing dialog
with other communities
who call themselves Christian.
Their first point and
really their only point is
that there can only be one holy
Catholic and Apostolic church
and that all the heterodox
are therefore not the church.
They have also encouraged the
designation of ecumenism as heresy.
This of course has
also repercussions
in how the Orthodox Church
deals with the other Christians
and non-Christians in
the Republic of Georgia.
One of my sources said well, they're
actually doing business for Moscow,
the Moscow Patriarchate
and the Russian church while
the Russian church can look--
can have its hands clean from
disrupting the Great Synod.
Another large conflict
of the Orthodox Church
in Georgia has involved a
small LGBT community there.
This conflict came to a
head on May 17, 21013.
A small group of demonstrators,
only a couple of dozen
at the most had gathered in Tbilisi
to observe the international
day against homophobia.
They were besieged by a huge
counterdemonstration led
by Orthodox priests
all of whom priests
and other demonstrators
were breathing violence
against the first group.
Those observing the Idaho
Day as its called fearing
for their very lives were
hustled on to buses by police.
The Orthodox Church has since named
the 17th of May to be Family Day.
This year, it was observed by the
presence of the World Congress
of Families, a group founded
in the United States encouraged
by official Russia and a group that
has been designated a hate group
by the Southern Poverty Law Center.
Now, I recognize that this issue is
one of no small controversy and one
that cannot be dealt
with at length here.
I would drop one observation
however into the mix.
Some officials of the
Orthodox Church referred
to homosexuality as a disease.
They do not necessarily however
mean this as an individual's disease
which would then elicit
a pastoral response
but rather they consider the
disease of the body politic,
that must therefore be
eradicated from the nation in order
to avoid apocalyptic consequences.
That's another talk altogether.
But since we are at the
Library of Congress,
I thought it would be appropriate
to do some bibliographic work,
specifically to speak of some
of the resources published
by the Orthodox Church in Georgia.
Periodical literatures slowly
began to become available
in the late 1980s and early
1990s published by the church.
There were also other pub-- also
other religious publications,
there was something called
the Old Orthodox Union
that was publishing newspapers
in the summer of 1990.
They were off the charts
obscurantists.
Where the first journals was
called [inaudible] is the Cross
of the Grapevine will reference
to the cross of St. Nino
that is described in hagiography,
first published in 1989.
An important newspaper Motley
[assumed spelling] or Grace
as you here, appeared
first in April 1990.
These and other publications
has this primary goal,
the basic education of the faithful,
who had generally been prohibited
from learning much of
anything about their faith.
Some had been baptized along the
way, a phenomenon not unknown
in other churches across
the Soviet Union,
but were still ignorant
of the fundamentals.
As the Georgian economy
strengthened at the beginning
of the 20th century, and
into its second decade,
the number of magazines and
journals proliferated in Georgia.
One of my acquisition goals has
been to acquire serial publications
of all sorts but especially
religious ones.
I have been able to buy issues
of the periodical published
by the eparchy in Svaneti
in farthest Ushguli
at the Lamaria Church that
was in the picture just
in the shadow of the glaciers.
And certainly, this is a sign of the
revival of the orthodoxy in Svaneti.
Just a sample of the others,
there's something called
Erti Kadageba, Once Sermon.
As the title indicates, it's
One Sermon by the patriarch
or by an archbishop or a
bishop or a priest or a monk
and these come out quite frequently.
At one time, there is something
called Kvakutxedi or cornerstone.
This builds itself as a
national religious journal
and so it's a little bit more on the
conservative side wherein the church
and the idea of church and nation,
church and state is
much more tightly held.
Some of these, I don't know if
they're in publication anymore,
I didn't-- I certainly
didn't see all of these
when I was there earlier
in May this year.
Maxvili Mesiisa, the
Sword of the Messiah
and this is the official publication
of the Urbnisi and Ruisi Eparchy
which is Northwest of Tbilisi.
I'm sorry, Mcqemsi Keteli,
Good Shepherd which is
just a general publication.
Krialosani or Prayer Beads,
another publication that tends to be
on the conservative side, Pudze or
foundation, and this is especially
for Georgians who live
outside of Georgia.
This and another one of-- with the
same goal could be found generally
only at the big Church of the
Holy Trinity with the idea
of the pilgrims visiting
the homeland,
would certainly visit the
new cathedral and there,
they could buy these publications.
I didn't see either
one of them last month.
Natlia or godparent, Axalgazrdoba,
especially for youth, Tanamemamule,
which means compatriot
was another publication
for Georgians living
outside of Georgia.
And as some of the
Georgians will know,
the any Georgian living outside
of Georgia is only temporarily
living outside of Georgia.
His holiness and the attitude, Ilia
II and some of his pastoral letters
in the long list of
people he is addressing,
will refer to those Georgians
temporarily living outside
of the homeland.
This is Gza da Cheshmariteba,
The Way and Truth
which is the official paper of
the Alaverdi Diocese that is
in Eastern Georgia, you can buy
some of the monks' honey here.
The church has been-- has been
redone since the first time I saw it
in 1990 when it was-- the inside
was all taken up with scaffolding
of the sort that made my fear
of heights much exaggerated.
Aliluia, a children's
publication and Maqvlovani.
This refers to the bramble bush
under which St. Nino lived during
her early years in Mtskheta
but it's also the word that's used
for the bramble bush in Exodus 3
where Moses encounters the
Divine Being in the burning bush
and as we know, the burning bush
is a type of a prefiguration
of the Virgin Mary,
that is something
in which divinity was enclosed
but was not consumed by divinity.
So, we've got Saint Nino and Moses
and the blessed Virgin Mary
all expressed and the title
of this journal put out by the
women's monastery in Mtskheta.
This then has been a very short
prcis of the Orthodox Church
in Georgia in some of its growth
into the leading institution
in Georgian society and a brief
introduction to some of the issues
that this church has faced
in this first generation
of Georgia's new independence.
Thank you and I think there's
a few minutes for questions.
Just a few, three questions.
You want to moderate the questions?
Anybody got a question?
Alex.
[ Inaudible Question ]
Crowded.
Controversially rebuilt, yes.
[ Inaudible Question ]
Part of it is architectural, I
didn't show you the backside of it
which has some modifications
that basically,
I think what they did was they put
a part of the old ruins on the side
of the church in an enclosure that
doesn't match anything, in a dark--
I think mostly glass
enclosure, right.
But it looks out of place and
of course, on the UNESCO list
of things, rebuilding things
from ruins is essentially a no-no
but I suppose I do side
with the church on this one
that the most important thing about
a church is that you can use it
and being ruins, you can't
use it so you fix it.
Now, they might have fixed it
better but that's the principle.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
They're locals.
A lot of them, converts at
the end of the Soviet period
in the early period of independence.
Some have accused the clergy of
being rushed into their orders
and not having received
enough education.
Some also say that they're
thieves but that's another--
that's probably more of a-- an
assessment of people who don't
like the church at all but there
is a problem with education
because the theological educational
institutions just weren't there.
And it's been a long
process and, you know,
25 years is too short a
time to really to regroup.
Cathy?
[ Inaudible Question ]
I'm sorry, the second
part of that question?
>> Cathy: I'm sorry?
>> Paul Crego: The second
part of the question?
[ Inaudible Questions ]
Oh, the Georgian or the
Russian churches very much agree
on ecumenism.
They don't like it.
Even though the Russian Church at
Synod, the upcoming Synod has tried
to play itself above
the fray statements
over the last 20 years have been
generally fairly anti-ecumenical
as to the other part of your
question which was Registration,
I don't believe there
is a registration
but there are still
property disputes.
I heard-- when I was there in May,
I heard about a Catholic
church being taken
over by an Orthodox church and
having its Catholic things taken out
and whitewashed and such.
One more, Angela?
[ Inaudible Question ]
There are some priests that
say nice things about Stalin
but I would say Stalin is remembered
better in Russia than is in Georgia
and that's been my impression.
So, is that--
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Oh, by older people sometimes but
it's so different from what it was.
I mean, having been there in
1990 and having returned 10 times
after that, I would never go back
to the empty shelves of 1990.
I mean that there were very
difficult years in the early '90s
in Georgia but-- and
there's still difficulties
because of the wide income
ranges that are present there.
Lots of poverty and a few people
like former Prime Minister Bidzina
Ivanishvili who have so much money
that in his well, I can only call
it a palace and my reference is too,
well, if you watched the Jetsons
and if you wanted to design a house
of a rich man on a
hill that would fit
into the Jetsons, this would be it.
He has a shark at least, and a
zebra and penguins in this building.
And he also has a place out in
Western Georgia and recently,
there were pictures of a large tree
that he had uprooted somewhere being
taken on a barge over the Black Sea
to wherever it was going
to be transplanted.
But that's Bidzina.
>> Levon Avnoyan: Yeah?
Stay here.
All right, this has
been as I said for me
to introduce Paul who's not only
a valued colleague but a friend.
I think he will agree with me when I
say that Georgia is a place you want
to visit, you have to visit and
you will always remember visiting.
It's-- It is special place
along with Armenia and Georgia,
special place in both our hearts.
I want to thank Dr. Crego
for a superb lecture.
I would love to thank
you for coming,
especially on this hot holiday week
and I hope you'll consider
visiting the African
and Middle Eastern
Division to do your research
or just to visit in a few trips.
And on June 10th, please
consider attending these--
the all-day seminar
conference on the Assyrians,
the modern day Assyrians
and Paul, thank you so much.
>> Paul Crego: You're welcome.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.